look no matter what phase of your life
you're in right now whether you're in
the you know new exciting phases like
the puppy lab of a business or
relationship or whatever you're doing
you're so excited about it or in this
steady face or a momentum phase no
matter where you're at at some point
you're going to hit a wall you're just
going to and when you hit a wall it is
very interesting when a person hits a
wall because initially when you hit a
wall you feel like everything's going to
collapse you feel like everything's
coming down you feel like every single
thing you are stressed out about you're
worried about it's going to collapse
it's almost like you feel it's the end
of life it's like Edna the world is
coming right and the way you behave and
react when you hit the wall creates a
habit in your life and one of the worst
habits there's a lot of people that say
they're you know the worst happen in
their life is this and this is the worst
happen and that's I would tell you one
of the worst habits if not the worst
habit in life is quitting quitting is a
terrible habit of pickup because you're
gonna keep quitting in your life you'll
keep quitting in your life and the next
thing you know every single time you hit
a wall you'll quit so I have a system
that I want to talk to you about today
ten different points a why people quit
and if you go through this and what you
need to do for your so now I'm going
through this right now no matter what
you're going through right now the
quitting phase there's something to do
to overcome it no matter what you're
going through right now but before I
even get into it I want you to even
think about in a completely different
way think about how old you are right
now I don't know how old you are right
now okay I want you to go back ten years
ago if you're thirty you were twenty
what were you worried about that was
keeping you up at night at twenty years
old ten years ago what were you worried
about what was keeping you up at night
was it a relationship a girlfriend a
school a teacher professor parent
argument crisis car payment ticket
suspension DUI
what was it ten years ago do you even
worry about that today was at the end of
the world no the same thing is with
business every single person that builds
a big business at many different points
of their career have to slay some
dragons you just have to slay some
dragons and the better you go within
time the easier it gets on slaying and
extracting so now let's talk about why
people quit ten different reasons
number one reason number one reason why
people quit where you hit a wall and say
things like I don't think I can do this
anymore
why am I putting myself through this
right I can't do this anymore why am I
putting myself through this you're being
a car I've did this many many different
different times in my life
the number one reason why I believe
people get into the quitting phase and
why people quit is they're overwhelmed
you're simply overwhelmed and when we're
overwhelmed in that state that's when
you either increase your identity as a
leader you stay the same or you go lower
it's very simple so when you're
overwhelm what could cause overwhelming
for instance think about it this way one
of them could be you know you're
performing you're building a business
and the next thing you know one of your
competitors is beating you you feel
overwhelmed and then you notice somebody
that opened a business even they have
less experience than you but they're
beating you you still feel overwhelmed
it could be you're not performing at a
level that you should be performing
you're overwhelm it could be somebody
that's a mentor of yours or somebody
that's pushing you from the top you feel
overwhelmed it could be somebody that is
challenging you you feel overwhelmed
it could be certain financial issues
you're facing you could feel overwhelmed
it could be many there it could be
you're running the business and you can
are telling yourself you know honestly I
don't think I can run a business because
I'm dealing with my marriage here in my
relationship and my kids here and my mom
told me the other day I'm not being a
good son and this person over here and
that text I got for my old friend and
I'm no longer a royal Laker fan or a
Cowboys fan and I just feel so
overwhelming I don't think I can handle
this I'm overwhelmed so it creates
pressure okay you feel overwhelmed
pressure easiest thing to do is what I
quit I can't do this anymore annually by
the way this is not just in business
this happens in sports when you're
playing sports and your kid and you're
playing for Coach that's very much
pushing everybody you say if you play
for Bill Belichick how do you think he
is in locker room you really think he's
kind of cake good job guys you did
phenomenal don't worry we lost don't
come to practice Monday you think Bill
Belichick is an easy coach to play for
you play from you're going to win
championships but it's not easy playing
for a coach like that if you're going to
make a decision to play for someone like
that it going to push you so imagine
your 16 year old kid you're playing for
this coach and you're number six by your
the six men on a basketball team you
want to get starting tombow you're not
because the side the kid is taking a
position away
you and the coach is pushing you you
feel pressured you come home you don't
know what to do you're talking to your
mom you're talking to your dad you don't
want to bring it up to your dad that you
want to quit basketball your mom says
maybe you ought to quit maybe it's not
don't worry about it baby's too much
pressure maybe your mom tells you go do
it and then that that's a habit on what
you do in that moment that's a habit on
what you do in that moment that's the
over one part the good news is yes
you're overwhelmed if you can get to do
the overwhelming faith you're going to
grow you be a whole different person
after that number two lack of results no
matter what you do if a person gets lack
of results and a lack of results is
purely a reflection of lack of activity
lack of results is not going to happen
accidentally let me explain to what I
mean by this let's just say you give me
somebody that's never played basketball
ever in their lives they've never played
basketball you may be watching and
saying honestly Pat I can't stand it
when use basketball analogies on value
tainment because I don't follow
basketball no problem I want you okay
you've never played basketball before
you never shot a single shot of
basketball in your life before I bring
you in okay you're 20 years old and you
and I our goal is for you to make ten
shots from the free-throw line okay if
you have to make ten shots from the
free-throw line what are the chances of
you making ten shots from the free-throw
line
if I only give you ten options ten
chances what are the chances can we say
zero because you've never played
basketball before so you're going to
shoot an air ball you're going to shoot
it over you're going to know maybe you
get lucky to make one you've never shot
masky about before but here's the second
equation what if I tell you have
unlimited amount of shots you take you
think you'll eventually make ten shots
yes see lack of result which is the
shots to make is a reflection of lack of
activity which if you only take shots
and you miss of course it's not going to
work an entrepreneur a businessman you
need to take so much result activity to
create results because you're an amateur
you're not an expert yet and so the
formula of capitalism guys I will tell
you one thing about capitalism in sales
people hate it when I say this it's a
100% proven where anybody can make it
anybody can make it anybody can make it
in the world of
eles in capitalism because it's purely a
mathematical formula simple as that it's
purely a mathematical formula but when
somebody doesn't get results because of
their activity then they quit and they
think it's the industry you know what it
didn't work real estate in and work out
for me hakumen has for hundreds of
thousands of people you know this ended
it didn't work out for me that didn't
work out for me no you're simply
creating a habit of quitting point
number three point number three is
self-sabotage self-sabotage my gosh
that's a that's a dangerous one because
self-sabotage happens when you're all by
yourself and nobody's around you so
you're in the car you're going home
you're by yourself you're telling
yourself things you're feeding yourself
things and then you start believing it
and so one of the things that you will
realize is you know the same people the
world has roughly 7.2 billion people
living in it today 7.2 billion people
living in it today roughly 400 million
are entrepreneurs out of the 7.2 billion
only 400 billion are entrepreneurs how
many do you think quit but they try to
entrepreneurship at some point think
about that 7.2 billion 400 million how
many quit so how many why do you think
those people quit because at some point
they convinced themselves that they
can't do it at some point they listen to
themselves that they can't do it and the
other guy who makes it he listened to
himself and make himself believe that he
can't do it when he was alone and nobody
was around self-sabotage is when you're
in your car by yourself self-sabotage is
when you're in your office by yourself
self-sabotage is when it's at night
everybody's asleep you're feeding
yourself in bed saying my gosh I can't
do it self-sabotage happens when you're
all alone by yourself and here's a good
news about self-sabotage you're ready
for the good news on sub sabotage the
same effort that it takes to sell
yourself that you can't do something
it's the same exact effort it takes to
sell yourself then you can do it it's
just you're great salesman you're just
selling this product just start selling
this product this product says you can't
do it this product says you can do it
this is an easy product to sell it's the
same effort
so start self sabotaging yourself and
tell yourself I can't do it and look
what I happen mark my work when I got
started as a brand spanking new
entrepreneur they told me put a list of
affirmations things you read to yourself
every day I had it everywhere one time
mentor Mike came to my house and I'll
never forget this he came to my house
and he was taking a shower because this
was a good friend of mine and next thing
you know he's in her for an hour I'm
concerned worried in there for an hour
he comes out he's screaming because he's
reading all of my affirmations and he's
fired up lit up man I feel so good I
said I read that every single day now I
feel so good right now I said I've read
it every day I didn't believe in myself
I was a guy that gave up on every single
thing let me tell you one thing about
this cat here
my dad till today has a trophy on his
desk okay in his house it's the only
trophy his son ever got okay this 6-4
240 body frame only got one trophy in
sports in his life you know what the
trophy was we lost to a team by 100
points when I was 14 years old
a hundred points we lost and we got a
trophy for losing hundreds at least stop
the game after 50 points these kids put
him through the you know 100 point Rafi
he still got it so I'm not I'm not
coming from a background of I was a
all-star pitcher and a baseball and
basketball starting lineup far from it I
never played organized sports in my life
ever but self-sabotage you got to learn
the art of going to the next side next
number four problem magnet
some people are problem agnates you know
you know I call a crap magnet if you
want to call it they just tend to
attract crap in their lives you know and
one of the reasons why people attract
crap in their lives and this is going to
be strange when you hear this and it's
going to be tough for some people to
hear this one of the reasons why people
attract crap in their lives is because
they want to and I'll tell you why they
want you because if you have crap in
your life you have an out why you didn't
make it so you you have to grab attract
crap because it's like well I didn't
make it because my family was going
through this well I didn't make it
because you know my car broke down well
I didn't make it because my teacher just
well I didn't make it because I had a
kid and I was a single father why I
didn't make it because my marriage I
don't well I didn't make it because I
got a deal why I didn't make it because
my car broke down no you kind of want
those things to happen to you so you can
advertise it and say that's why I did it
make it here's the kicker
those same people that make it they also
had those things happen to them as well
they just don't advertise it they don't
advertise it because the more you
advertise it the more you attract crap
unless you advertise it
unless you're attracting crap think
about if a if a girl goes out there and
she's at a bar and she advertises and
says oh you guys won't understand what
just happened my boyfriend just cheated
on me and he broke up with me and I hate
him so much she's a target here are a
bunch of single drunk men that are
saying target let me take advantage this
opportunity now it's a target somebody
goes out there and says oh you know I
just came out of the casino and you go
to bar late at night you go to casino
and you go to a bar and you say oh you
won't believe what just happened you
know what happened I just went to the
casino I want $20,000 cash meant I got
in my pocket right now
$20,000 cash what are you potentially
attracting a bunch of people I can jump
you outside and take you to any 20 grand
from you're attracting crap because
you're advertising to attract crap if
you go out and keep talking about my
life sucks this happened to me that
happened to me you're telling the world
please send more crap my way please send
more crap my way and eventually you quit
bow number five bad decisions
life is about decisions choices quitting
is also about bad decisions bad
decisions could be what somebody keeps
telling you you can't build a business
or you shouldn't be in a certain thing
you're doing or this is just not for
you're not smart enough for and you keep
going back and being around this person
and you don't know it just like you
never know who you got a flu from or
cold from you could have shook someone's
hand who went like this and they had a
flu and they gave it to you you will
never be able to pinpoint where you got
that flu from it's the same exact thing
when you sit down next to somebody and
they tell you what are you doing doing
business when you can't build a business
you don't even know it you just got the
flu that flu is called you're about to
quit that's what bad decisions are
that's a bad decision bad decision is
you should have stayed at the office on
Friday night when you didn't hit your
numbers you wanted to go to the
nightclub that's about this and why go
into the nightclub for what you don't
have a hundred grand in the bank yet you
have a major millions yet for what go to
the main club
bang bang nightclub for what yo you're
going over here and you know I've really
don't feel good today you should go read
or develop or do something or study
immerse yourself in your industry you go
and hang out and go shoot pool for what
bad decisions we can't control that
decisions you control that decisions
because you make the decision number six
procrastination procrastination get so
many people words we'll do it later
we'll get it done later not right now
maybe later maybe this may be that's a
terrible terrible habit it's just as bad
as quitting because typically quitting
is a byproduct of somebody that
constantly procrastinate and then all of
a sudden they start quitting everything
so procrastination hurts a lot of people
number seven is an interesting one that
I want to dive into and that's being a
loner being a loner hurts a lot of
people in business because look let me
let me just put it to you this way you
know if you're married and you're going
through issues when you're married the
worst thing you could do is not have
somebody else that you can have a
conversation with that tells you
typically someone that's ahead of you
and marriage so if you've been married
three years may not be a bad idea to
talk to somebody that's been married for
twenty years and they got you know three
kids and you know whatever so they're
gonna tell you about it's normal what
you're going through here's what
happened to my wife and I here's what we
want to learn it's fine oh man so I'm
not by myself if you're a loner you
think you're the only one that's going
through this problem so you oh my gosh
it's only me because you're a loner
you're afraid you're loner now you got
it you gotta have some people around
that are similar level that you've not
hired to tell you I've been there before
I've been there before here's what
you're going through so in the world of
business you know you hit a certain wall
and you don't know how to get through it
and you're not talking to the right
person and you say man I'm the only
person that's going through this I must
be horrible at what I'm doing in this
business I'm an underachiever there's no
way in the world I'm gonna make it in
life and pop pop pop nope you're simply
a loner it's not true your loner your
being by yourself you're not around
other people are going to kick your butt
a little bit or lift you up when you
need it loner
it's a difficulty being a loner doesn't
help you now keep this in mind what do I
mean by being a loner sometimes a
contradiction to that is well Pat I
don't really get it because aren't you
supposed to be a loner when you become
an entrepreneur you're all by yourself
and it's you know the you're alone at
the top and all this you know that whole
singular you're alone at the top
like what you're alone at the top are
you kidding me who's alone at the top
how many million dollar homes are there
in America - how many million dollar
homes are there in the world three come
on man there are millions of million
dollar homes there's a million people at
the top that's not alone you just got to
find them no it's a lonely thing at the
top it's not now there's times where
you're in your car by yourself on the
way to the top maybe you feel like
lonely out of time sure sure you do but
you can still find some people that are
at a similar position as you if not
higher that can lift you up
number eight self doubt self doubt man
the word doubt dwell when we sit there
and dwell on a problem then we doubt
ourselves you know these D words are
very very dangerous emotions with
dwelling and doubting and against self
doubt comes lack of activity and lack of
activity produces no results then you
question your abilities then you say I
don't know if I can really do this and
why am I putting myself through this and
then you quit so you got to know when
you're going to do one of the things
about when you haven't doubt or your
dwelling the best thing you can do is
the following thing when it's happening
you got to catch it oh I'm dwelling I'm
doubting Oh we'll stop you're not
winning
you're not literally I would speak to
myself I'm not buying this my dad could
tell you my dad just flown in town to
visit uh spend some time with us for
Thanksgiving
my dad will tell you we'd be at family
gatherings and somebody would say
something that's their truth and I would
say you know what I'm not buying that
that's your mindset combined not buying
that a my dad would say Pat why do you
say us I'm not buying that mind Sam not
going to allow my brain to buy that
there's no way in the world I'm buying
that it's for sale the world's gonna buy
because it's for sale everybody wants to
buy things for sale I want to pay full
price that's what I want to buy I'm not
buying that okay Pat okay your knob I'm
not buying that I'm not buying that all
women are like this I'm not buying that
all men are like this I'm not buying
that all entrepreneurs are like this I'm
not buying that I'm not buying that
today in the political world what is it
all Republicans are like this all
Democrats are like this all blacks all
Hispanics all Muslims I'm not buying
that all I'm not buying that so you got
to be
be aware when you're going into the
self-doubt mode and you say nobody my
family's ever make it I'm not buying
that I'm gonna make it you don't
understand I don't have a degree I'm not
buying that
I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make it so
you got identified stop and say I'm not
buying that
I'm not buying something for sale just
say it with me repeat it with me I'm not
buying that say it out loud baby I'm not
buying that don't buy it it's on sale
pay full price it's the best products
you'll ever buy when you pay full price
next number nine selective hearing it's
very problematic if you listen to the
wrong thing let me tell what selective
hearing is selective hearing is the
following I could have a conversation
when you're down and out and you're
overwhelmed and you want to quit
everything you look for you look for
signs to what to quit selective hearing
so you'll drive in a car and a sign will
say too much pressure in your life maybe
you ought to come into work yet Kaiser
Permanente in 49 thousand dollar salary
and benefits and all the something like
that's a sign because I was thinking
about health insurance it's a sign God's
given me for me to quit no no it's
selective hearing is what it's called
that's simply what it is because right
across the street there was a sign that
said you can have all your dream so you
didn't look at it because you sign in
with nope that's not true I'm looking
over here selective hearing selective
hearing is you can talk to somebody and
they talked and they challenged you and
they remind you of things you've done
where you could go out and go in and
they tell you those two areas that you
need to improve selective hearing says
did you hear what he said on the
conference call he told me those two
things I need to improve what he's
trying to say is I'm not good this is
why I can't do it no he told you already
selective hearing you chose to listen to
this selective hearing selective hearing
you got to choose what you what you
choose to listen to that's selective
hearing number 10 last one is who's in
your ear let me tell you why who's in
your ear we get thousands and thousands
of comments every day on value teaming
and people say I watch this religiously
I was at the life insurance convention
is called now but every single year
where all these insurance companies get
to get any of the biggest insurance
companies in the world I was there for
two days
these are every
when you do your strong negotiations
this this year's was epic because it was
a completely different story so anyways
so I'm there several guys constantly Pat
one guy comes who's a very very
successful 100 million dollar year type
of guy he says I will never miss an
episode on value team and never so
you're the first thing I start my day
off with i watch every single episode on
value tainment
every single episode on value tim it
that's great but even a value taemin
episode can only be 30 minutes long you
got to figure out a way to find out
who's feeding your ear who's feeding you
so who's feeding you who's in your ear
who's in your ear do you control who's
in your ear who has influence over you
who has influence over you who's telling
you what to do who is it people that are
ahead is the people that are feeding you
fear the most important appointment of
the day is your last appointment of the
day you know who the last appointment of
the day's let me I did an episode once
if you haven't watch it you gotta watch
it it's called the most important
appointment of an entrepreneur let's put
a thumbnail of it Dennis so they can see
it and we'll put a link somewhere as
well Rebecca so they can see it as well
it's the most important appointment of
an entrepreneur it's called the last
pulmonary that you know what it is it's
the last person you talk to when you go
to sleep you know who's the last person
you talked to before you go to sleep
whoever that person is to you maybe your
girlfriend your boyfriend mom dad
brother sister wife husband whoever the
last person you talked to before you go
to sleep whatever their feed your ear
that's how you're going to go to sleep
dreaming or having nightmares about it
so if I go to sleep and my spouse says
babe this is scary babe I see being so
stressed I see gray hair I'm seeing this
this this this this fear fear fear I go
to sleep with fear I wake up with fear
this is what I want to do but if I go to
still my last appointment of the day and
the person says babe I know it's tough
babe but I don't know why babe I just
believe in you babe honey I don't know
what it is I just believe in you son I
just believe in you you know it brother
I believe in you bro I believe in you
sister I believe in your girlfriend I
believe in you I believe in you there's
only two people in the world you need to
believe in you
one is yourself and one is just another
person I don't care who it is just
another person if you got these two
people
you can take over the world if you want
it to so you gotta make sure you talk to
somebody that believes in you and you
got to make sure you believe in yourself
because if you don't do those two things
you're facing this right here in
quitting as an entrepreneur you don't
want to do that so with that being said
this is a this is a episode that I've
been very excited about by the way this
year this board I'm holding on to was
given to me as a gift
repeller Woodworks I met him at Texas
A&M young kid as an entrepreneur who's
doing a great job out there
this past week when I was out there but
if you got any questions about today's
episode comment on the bottom on
quitting maybe you have some other thing
that I want to put down there as well so
share this video with somebody I will
tell you there's a lot of people that
are going through a lot of difficulties
right now in America especially with the
you know challenges we're facing in
America politically some people are
thinking about quitting their life let
alone businesses what I'm talking about
but there are a lot of people that just
think that's the end of life so share
this message with a handful of people
you'd be amazed by the response you're
going to get from some people how
grateful there'll be anyways with that
being said look if you haven't
subscribed to this channel please do so
make sure you subscribe to this channel
another thing I want to tell you guys
that we just did in the last episode is
we are looking for a new pillow we're
looking for a new pillow for value
taming this pillow is a pillow that
we've had for now I want to say about a
year we've had on this channel we're
looking for a new pillow you can be
creative with it it's got to have the
YouTube sign on it and value taming
whatever you want to do to be custom
several people have already emailed us
told us they're sending a pillow over
and we'll choose a pillow by the end of
the year for 2017 and if your pillow is
chosen well obviously show some of them
but if your pillow is chosen
we will definitely let everybody know
that you send the pillow to us the
address to send it out to is 5,000 won
Spring Valley Road 5,000 won Spring
Valley Road that's 1155 East is the
suite number 1155 East is a suite number
Dallas Texas zip code 75606
you